um how have you been dealing with uh
because you know I feel like you you do
live your life outward online sometimes
right
um you know I feel like we've kind of
seen you go through like public you know
issues when it comes to maybe depression
or you know maybe some of your previous
relationships just you kind of gone
through a lot of stuff and like we've
seen it how are you doing today
um that's a good question uh today I'm
still like the same person you know I'm
so kind of the same person but
I'm just less I try to be less open uh
on social media and everything just
because I I don't feel like it makes
anything better but the reason why I try
to be open on social media is because
there's a lot of people out there going
through the same [ __ ] you know we're all
human you could be you could have 10
million followers 10 million dollars
like life's still gonna hit you you
can't get away from life but at the end
of the day I feel like I feel like I'm
just going through the same thing but I
kind of deal with my
um you know my thoughts and everything
in a different way now right now that
I'm getting older I talk to people I uh
you know just have conversations with
myself but I still try to be open you
know have you gone to therapy I have
gone to therapy was it helpful
no it wasn't no no no how many times did
you go though I've been to three
different therapists and maybe I need to
find the right one that's that's what
they say but I um I don't know man I
feel I know it's supposed to be like a
judge-free Zone kind of thing but I feel
like when I'm telling my story I'm not
judging but they kind of don't get it
you know and it's it's hard to talk to
someone who doesn't get it when you say
this this and that and they're like um
but you know I I'm not sure maybe I need
to
[ __ ] you know what you need I don't know
what I need you need a hero's dose of
mushrooms
[Music]
that's what she needs is that the truth
yeah oh man or you need to hop on a
plane put your lady go to that [ __ ]
Costa Rica yeah do some [ __ ]
Ayahuasca but but here's the crazy thing
here's the crazy thing serious I know I
hear you and I've and I've heard that
and I've I've been told that but I love
life bro like no you're gonna love life
more no listen bro I promise you it's
not a it's I'm not telling you something
like in a negative way like yeah
everyone not you not just yeah anybody
in the world should do psychedelics
at least once
all the time
yeah here's the thing with me though I
feel like I have a great balance like I
love life but then like I hate life but
to you having having that pain having
that anger having that internal flame
inside me pushes me to do certain things
you know push pushes me to make certain
music for people you know what I mean
who who So like um Aaron Rodgers he's a
football player dude no okay so he's
[ __ ] back-to-back NFL MVP
this year he's been terrible but
two years ago he said he went to Costa
Rica did Ayahuasca and I like unlocked
something in his brain and he's just
like [ __ ] he's an amazing football
player and I mean he's always been
amazing but what changed he just said
that he like understood the world more
he became more self-aware he became more
like it it really kind of kills your ego
it kind of like yeah you should do some
shrooms at least I'm gonna try it I got
some for you I'll let you know okay
before you leave here you'll have some
okay
but I I like I like the balance between
between happy and sad though I don't
want to be happy all the time you don't
want to be happy all the time but you
also want to like have an understanding
of why you're yeah like there's probably
a lot of like repressed [ __ ] right you
don't even know is there right for real
like I had a my homie uh I would say his
name but he's an industry guy uh he said
that he he well I knew this guy to be
like one of the more degenerate pieces
of [ __ ] of like all time gamble did a
bunch of [ __ ] cocaine he's always
sniffing blow off hookers boxes just a
psychopath right okay great guy though I
love him uh but he did Ayahuasca and he
hasn't uh touched drugs he hasn't
gambled he got married he had a baby he
got [ __ ] wow he's like professionally
doing better than he's ever done like
Ayahuasca so what's Ayahuasca it's like
a um it's like a drink like a tea that
stems from a root that is
DMT based but it's kind of like peyote
it's kind of different I'm not too
familiar with peyote but it's it's a lot
more intense uh you drink it DMT kind of
no DMT is like
yeah it is DMT but it's a slower version
of DMC like if you smoke DMT have you
ever smoked DMT no I haven't I can't say
I have yeah if you smoked DMT you would
just go away for like a half hour
Ayahuasca your present in the moment
it's like six hours yeah of like you but
you do it with a shaman
to work you through it you know
and they guide you they guide you and
then you come out the other side like a
[ __ ] like I my friend who we were
talking about told me it was like doing
30 years of therapy in six hours wow is
there anyone
it hasn't worked for nobody I know no
one that went crazy like [ __ ] no I got a
couple of homies who like they go to
Costa Rica three times a year just to
get their [ __ ] like get just to get yeah
get their [ __ ] their mind right [ __ ]
hey because you know what like all that
[ __ ] all the therapy [ __ ] is cool and
it's helpful I think everybody should go
to therapy talk to somebody yeah
um but like the medicine that they try
to put you on that's some [ __ ] yeah
like medication also some [ __ ] [ __ ] like
do some mushrooms bro yeah okay it's not
natural kind of thing yeah yeah I feel
like talking to someone is important
though it is important but talking to
someone who kind of understands or is
willing to listen even if they don't
understand yes but the other thing is is
you're in a position where a lot of
people you probably talk to
do they depend on you in some way in
some way yeah so don't talk to anybody
who depends on you for anything yeah but
there's there are also people who depend
on that aren't like that makes sense
selfish that makes sense of course but
you know not everyone is like extremely
selfish and some people are willing to
you know kind of step outside of who
they are and understand you know